Hello friends,
I am Karen also known as Doña Mari
and in this video I am going to make you a minitutorial
to help me recover my account
which was unfairly blocked,
I am really very sad and I would like to be helped,
so if you want to help me stay and watch this video,
good
the first thing you have to do is log into your account.
settings and privacy,
report a problem,
go downstairs,
put privacy,
inform
and put another one on it,
Are you going to get stung and need more help?
Here is a nice comment about hello
I want to report an error this blocked the account of
e Iker en arroba e Iker en 8
and well,
whatever you want
and will be added
I will leave the photos from my account here as well.
and well that was all I hope you can help me